[Music]
good morning everybody it's seven
o'clock a dramatic development overnight
with first details emerging about the
suspected terrorists killed in a car
explosion in liverpool an asylum seeker
believed to have made a homemade bomb
the securities minister damian hines is
with us very shortly plus an allegation
about the prime minister's father he
says he has no recollection of more on
that in an exclusive report shortly and
the former yorkshire cricketer azeem
rafiq will give evidence this morning
about his allegations of racism at the
club we'll speak to his lawyer later
this hour and we'll bring you his
evidence actually as well live at 9 30
plus
why is joanna lumley so angry about what
just happened there underwater
explosions like that one we'll talk to
her later on and
with the sultans
[Music]
it's your ear worm for this morning
ladies and gentlemen john illsley was
part of one of the biggest selling rock
bands in history he'll tell us about
life in dire straits at a quarter to
nine it's tuesday the 16th of november
the prime minister's father says he has
no recollection and no reply after he's
accused of inappropriately touching a
senior conservative female mp
and i can remember a really prominent
man
smacking me on the backside about as
hard as he could and going oh rumsey
you've got a lovely seat stanley johnson
that's me
do you have a response
i have no recollection
at all
and no required
reveal the first details about the
suspected terrorists killed in a car
explosion in liverpool believed to be a
32 year old asylum seeker
overnight four men arrested in
connection with the incident have been
released by police who say they found
significant items out of property here
former yorkshire player azim rafiq will
appear before mps this morning and is
expected to give details about alleged
racism at the club
we are live in westminster for that
qriket fixture that will see racism
within the sport go under the microscope
betrayal
anger in the north of england as uh sky
news understands the eastern leg of hs2
railing to leeds has been scrapped
space wars the u.s says a russian
weapons test has created a wave of
debris which could badly damage the
international space station
[Music]
good morning a senior conservative mp
has told you she was inappropriately
touched by the father of the prime
minister caroline knox a former minister
said that stanley johnson had touched
her at the conservative party conference
in 2003.
he told sky news today he had no
recollection of her and no reply
caroline knocks was speaking to our
political editor beth rigby as part of a
discussion with female mps over violence
against women
the abduction and murder of sarah
everard was a watershed moment for this
country it ignited debate about the
pervasive threat of sexual violence
faced by women whatever their background
whatever their politics
like so many of us it led these four mps
to reflect on their own experiences i
can't remember the amount of times i've
been sexually assaulted in my life in
one way or another i don't know why i
just felt so ashamed i can remember
being on a school trip to london zoo and
a group of and i'm going to say men
just grabbed hold of me and groped me
and his hands were touching my breasts
while he was cutting my hair
but sexual misconduct is not just a
private matter it intrudes into public
life too does being an mp
and being
having a massively powerful public role
does it change it for you in one regard
it does it does stop so sexual
harassment and abuse people tend not to
grope up you only grope someone who you
can sack
oh you know i don't i don't think that's
accurate
i've had male mps stick their hands on
my backside in strangers bar i can wind
the clock back and i can remember a
really prominent man
smacking me on the backside about as
hard as he could and going oh rumsey
you've got a lovely seat
oh great um i'd have punched him in the
face
so and that's that's my that's my
problem is who didn't
probably johnson in the face stanley
johnson stanley johnson did that to me
ahead of the o5 election so it was
blackpool i don't know what years for
2013
i didn't do anything and that i feel
ashamed by that no you shouldn't feel
ashamed because when i say i've
approached him in the face that's
because i am and now you probably would
now you would probably say something
party conference 18 years ago it sticks
in the mind of women in equality select
committee chair caroline knox for
stanley johnson seemingly hard to
remember
caroline knox accused you of touching
her inappropriately in 2003 and said you
said oh
romzy what a lovely seat do you have a
response to this mr johnson what i'm
showing you is caroline knocks accusing
you of touching her inappropriately in
2003.
do you have a response
i have no recollection of caroline legs
at all
mps can't change the past but they can
push for a better future there's
discussions in parliament about whether
or not sexual harassment should actually
become a crime do you think the
government
think that this is a priority what would
you like to see happen a uh public
sexual harassment a specific crime that
sends a firm message it also helps you
to identify those perpetrators how can i
put this delicately early on in their
offending journey is there a cultural
problem at the top of government where
perhaps
politicians aren't quite getting it
since the metoo movement we have
moved on culturally without question to
know that every single woman has had an
experience like this to know that we
know that what we haven't done
culturally is accepted that if everybody
knows a victim
then everybody knows a perpetrator
for a conservative mp to make an
allegation like this against the pm's
father is remarkable
what's sadly unremarkable is just how
commonplace these experiences are beth
rigby sky news
security minister is with us now damian
hines of course want to ask you about
liverpool and what happened what on
earth has happened there but first quick
thought on the allegations against um
stanley johnson from caroline knox how
will the party be investigating those
allegations
so okay i i just don't know the details
of the um
of the allegation that um the talking
about that we've just been that we've
just been hearing about and
what i can say is that yeah overall in
terms of
any harassment of women and broader
violence against women and girls there's
an absolute priority for government i'm
not linking that to what's just been
said you'll understand i'm not in a
position to to to be able to comment but
we do take extremely seriously um these
issues but i'm sure what you can say is
that no matter how far back an
allegation goes um if it was as part of
a tory party conference or an event that
was organized by the conservative party
you will investigate that surely so i'm
genuinely not in a position to be able
to give you more information than than
than what you have if there are
investigations to be had then of course
they will of course they will take place
i can't i can't speak to the detail of
of the allegation or the circumstance
because i just don't know and i've just
heard i've just been hearing this this
morning okay um i'm sure we'll hear more
about it during the course of the day
talk to me about what's happened
in liverpool how was this attacker
able to make an explosive device
well these are matters of course that
the police are looking into the
investigation is moving
is moving at pace you'll have heard the
statement from northwest county
terrorism police that
you know they are discovering more by
the hour but nevertheless it can take
quite some time could be weeks before
the absolutely full picture is known of
how this came about um
you know what what the motivation was
uh if potentially other people were
involved and and so on so we need to
leave space and time
for the police to to do their work and
my thoughts and yours i know and all
viewers thoughts would be with the
the people of liverpool this has been a
uh absolutely terrible event very
upsetting unsettling for many i know the
police in merseyside have been
putting on extra uh reassurance
visibility uh on the streets
and as i say our thoughts are very much
with the people of the city and and
everybody affected by this incident okay
let me put it another way how concerned
are we about lone wolves that during the
pandemic have managed to be in their
bedrooms tapping away on their computers
and being radicalized
you should be concerned of course so i
mean we use the term lone wolf a lot
sometimes it's it's a bit it can be a
little a little misleading because it
gives a certain picture
of of an individual but it certainly is
true that we've seen a move over time a
shift from um these sort of
what we call directed attacks you know
part of a bigger organization where
people are following
instructions sometimes quite complex in
their organization and move from that to
more
self-directed self-radicalized
individuals or small groups really
totally totally alone because people
talk to one another they take advice
they give hints but but yes that there
has been that move and you mentioned
lockdown of course uh during the
lockdown periods there have been more
people spending more time in front of
computer screens and we know that you
know when that happens for a very small
minority very very small narrative
people but there can be um
radicalization with with very very bad
so it's something that we've been aware
of
that that's happened that people are
being radicalized as a result of of uh
so i'm afraid it's not it's not brand
new okay i mean it's
radicalization self-radicalization but
that's on the internet the the
propaganda the way that people make
contact with one another and so on that
that is not a new development but but
like like a number of things
the trends that we saw through through
the coronavirus period through through
lockdown um have changed modus operandi
and in this case yes they will have
exacerbated increase the amount of time
that people are spending um online and
for some that that means very very badly
so if we were aware of that why then in
february at the very height of the
pandemic did we reduce the alert level
so
the alert level is determined
independently of ministers it's not
something i determine or the home
secretary determines we have a body
uh jtac the joint terrorism analysis
center who are experts in this area and
they use the alert level it's a way that
law enforcement security services and
others um
can can calibrate
uh what they are doing the protective
security measures that are needed but
look we've been a high alert for a very
long time now and that that's the
important thing you know we need people
to be
we talk about alert but but not alarmed
we need people to be vigilant if people
see something
suspicious something that isn't right uh
to report and of course in this
particular incident anybody who has any
information pleased to come forward
either directly to north west police or
you can always call crime stoppers
anonymously indeed so i understand that
minister but you know if we were aware
um or the security services were aware
that at the high or a pandemic would
mean that more lone wolves whatever you
want to call them pathetic thugs who
want to kill women in hospital or people
who were at a remembrance service if we
knew that potentially there were more of
them because of the pandemic why would
we reduce the alert level so the alert
level was
substantial meaning uh an attack was
likely and and and we really
no no no that that that that was it we
reduced it to that yeah yes that that
was it
and there are different calibrations um
depending on particular intelligence
available
at the time and as i say these are ways
that
the public agencies the law enforcement
bodies that that keep us safe can can
help to calibrate
their response and what they do but the
alert has been high for a very long
period of time and whenever the alert is
is high it means that these things i'm
afraid uh sadly tragically can happen
and and of course as we have seen
periodically do given what we saw in
liverpool at the weekend was that the
right decision
was what the right decision that we
reduce the alert level well as i say
these these are not decisions that i
make or ministers made
they we entrust professionals
experts in the field what's your opinion
uh my my opinion is i i absolutely trust
them to make those to make those correct
judgments and can i also just say okay i
mean in my position i i have the
privilege of
seeing working with hearing from
the amazing people who work in our in
our security services uh and in and in
law enforcement keeping us safe they are
working night and day
to protect us um from attacks and and
although an instance such as this one is
appalling absolutely awful um there are
also
multiple times when we are protected
from this there have been over 30
late stage plot disruptions in the last
in the last few years okay given that
you said that you wouldn't call him a
lone wolf what would you call him
i i didn't say that and in fact if i
would say one thing it's that i can't um
i can't comment on the detail of this
case at all for reasons you'll
understand yes
it's a but
it is a live investigation uh and it's
very very important that the police
uh have these
have the investigation whether you what
your viewers of this matter how have
they have the space to be able to
to be able to to do the investigation
a long time since i read my central law
for journalists but i know that your
comments about what you think about this
guy is not going to impact on the
investigation it is look it is a live
investigation there's always the
possibility that there may be other
people um involved we don't know that
the police said yeah
about him if that is the case
uh then then obviously they'll respond
appropriate and arrests made um if uh if
necessary what do you think of the uh
what do you think of the taxi driver i'm
not
okay
please please understand and i think you
do that i'm not in a position you can
comment on the bravery of the taxi
driver i comment on on the details of
the case what i can say is
thank god mr perry is out of hospital um
thank god others were not uh
were not uh injured or killed we can be
very very extremely grateful for that
in the case in his case mr perry's case
i mean he's been through a terrible
terrible trauma and i think it's
important also that he has uh afforded
privacy to to deal with chairman of the
party was very happy yesterday to say
that he um he thought his bravery went
out of uh you know was above and beyond
what you would expect and and kate look
we're all of course um immensely
pleased and grateful um
uh as i say that that the he he is now
out of hospital that that is a wonderful
thing we are
pleased and grateful that others were
not were not hurt the exact sequence of
uh what what has happened has to be
something that the has to be something
that the police invest again come
forward with over time okay i wasn't
necessarily asking about that but okay
hs2 um it's part of it's going to be
scrap what reaction can you reasonably
expect i suppose uh from the people in
the north who you promised so much to at
the last election
so as my understanding it's not you'll
understand obviously transport is not my
department but i understand the
integrated rail review comes out later
this week and only when that comes out
do we know do we know what's in it
uh i think we know before that that part
because and not least because uh we've
heard from labor we've also heard uh
from the um the um uh uh
ministers in not the world i'm looking
for mayors of of the towns involved who
are all saying that you know it's an
absolute betrayal that you are scrapping
that leg of hs2 that lead goes up to
lead
so i i am not aware of that because the
the because the integrated
is the integrated real review i don't
believe you is due out but not this
morning it's coming it's coming later
this week and when it comes we'll be
able to see well it won't be me on your
show that day but you'll be able to talk
to somebody sitting in this seat about
it well it's our understanding
what's your view what do you think that
people up in the north will think when
they will promise the earth for their
votes and it looks as though that's not
going to happen i think we're very
leveling up because i think we're
absolutely committed to leveling up i
think that is runs through it is infused
who don't want to get on a fast train in
everything government does transport
also is part of that and so uh and so
many other things on the specifics of
the railways we're going to have to wait
for the integrated rail review okay well
we do know what's going to happen as far
as covid and boosters are concerned
because the prime minister was talking
about it yesterday and it does look as
though you're going to have to have your
booster in order to be able to travel
overseas
so we want people to
to get their boosters um you know the
the vaccination program as you know has
been a
has been enormously important and
enormously successful it helps to keep
us
helps to keep us all safe we're inching
back
towards uh towards normality i think
that's a good thing i think it's what
people it's what people welcome so my
encouragement to everybody is when you
get the invitation
to get the uh to get the booster to go
ahead and do it
not as successful as you would want it
to be you were aiming for half a million
people a day being vaccinated it was
only 250 000 yesterday
so i haven't looked to the counter for
yesterday
i always i always trust thank you you
should thanks but but
i think you're making my point for me
well i'm not because i'm saying actually
i'm i think i'm doing exactly the
opposite which is you said half a
million people a day were going to get
their boosters 250 000 and if you don't
have your the um suggestion is that you
won't be able to go on your holidays
well when i say you're making a point
for me what i mean is we want people to
get there to get the booster jab and
that is yeah you're blackmailing this
i'm not blackmailing
anybody and it is it's good for all of
us
it's good for us as individuals it's
good for us as a as a society and this
is how we are you know with the
vaccination this has been how we've been
able to to start to move out of this
what's been a very very difficult period
for so many people a tragic period for
for those who've lost who've lost loved
ones and the the booster jab is is the
very important next stage okay good to
talk to you thank you thank you for
joining us much appreciated thank you
and just a reminder if you are heading
out this morning then of course you can
catch up with our interviews on our
website uh you can go to our live blog
to watch the program there you can go to
our website skynews.com
uh you can also check out clips on my
twitter feed for later on if you would
like to in just a few minutes time we
will be distilling what the minister has
uh said and you'll find that at caberly
well as we were discussing with the
minister there the first details of the
suspected terrorists killed in liverpool
car explosion have been revealed sadia
is standing by in liverpool for us again
this morning um hello to you sadia what
more can you tell us
hello okay so there have been several
developments uh through yesterday
evening and overnight let's start with
the suspect the police named him
yesterday as imad al sulamin
it's understood that he was an asylum
seeker from a country in the middle east
and that he had been in the uk for some
time
and that he had some mental health
issues now last night we heard more
reports
from people who knew him a couple who he
had briefly lived with who described him
as
in one report as a diligent student of
christianity and they said that they had
routinely prayed with him now in terms
of the police investigation
for um people who had been arrested all
in their 20s
since sunday had been released last
night
and the police investigation is
continuing with cordon still in place
including here at rutland avenue where
police say they found significant items
and it's thought that the suspect had
rented a place here just recently and it
is from here that he got into the taxi
to make that short journey um to
liverpool women's hospital where the
device was detonated and police have
previously said that they believe he
manufactured the device and that he
built it
in the taxi on his way there
okay
thank you my goodness
still to come on the program for you
this morning as the terror threat is
raised following the explosion in
liverpool we'll speak to major general
chip chapman former head of
counter-terror at the ministry of
defence
uh cricketer azim rafiq will give
evidence to a parliamentary committee
this morning about his claims of racism
at yorkshire cricket club we'll talk to
his lawyer
shortly and five-year-old liam scott
there he is now cancer-free after his
family raised funds so he could raise a
receive rather a revolutionary vaccine
treatment in new york liam and his mom
claire will be with us
very shortly
and joanna lumley talks to us as she
supports a new campaign to reduce the
number of underwater explosions that
take place during the construction of
offshore wind farms
[Music]
let's talk about cricket then should we
mps will today begin an investigation
into allegations of racism at yorkshire
cricket club the former player at the
center of the scandal azeem rafiq is due
to appear before a parliamentary inquiry
this very morning
our sports correspondent tom parmenter
is in westminster forest where mr rafiq
will be giving evidence good morning tom
what are we expecting
over the last few weeks of course a lot
of people have had their say on the
racism scandal within cricket but the
whistleblower who started all this asean
rafiq will finally this morning get to
speak freely about the racism that he
suffered at headingley the way the club
dealt with the allegations that he put
to them and how
the the impact of all that led him to
a very very dark place indeed he'll be
speaking under parliamentary privilege
which means there will he can name names
if he wants to he can speak freely
because there will be no legal reprisals
because of that and sky news understands
that there are other yorkshire players
who in the last week or two have been
taking legal advice in case they are
named today by azeem rafiq and dragged
in to this scandal the session will be
overseen by julian knight mp who leads
the
digital culture
media and sport committee across party
committee of mps and he has already made
his views quite clear he said that this
is about endemic racism and he also said
of yorkshire the club must be held
accountable for its culture well that
process will start here this morning at
9 30.
okay tom thank you of course we'll cover
that for you here on sky news as the
scene rafik's evidence to the digital
culture media and sport committee gets
underway from 9 30 this morning
uh still to come this morning let's tell
you about um a poorly and yet
presidential uh when joe biden met the
chinese leader xi jinping at a virtual
summit overnight the chinese leader
called mr biden old friend while the u.s
president said the two countries must
not veer into conflict
steve bannon a former aide of president
donald trump has appeared in court in
the united states after surrendering to
fbi agents he's facing contempt charges
after defying a subpoena from a house
committee investigating january's
storming of the u.s capitol building
there is nothing about this case that
reflects the pursuit of the equal
justice under the law
this thing was a scam from the beginning
the committee that was convened here was
convened exclusively of people who have
made prejudgments and announced them
publicly
breaking news on uh the jobs front now
let's talk to our business correspondent
helen and smith hey helen and what are
the figures
morning okay so we've had the monthly uh
figures for jobs and employment across
the uk and while unemployment is down uh
a little bit down 0.5 there were a
couple of really really interesting
things this morning that i want to draw
out firstly payroll employees for the
month of october now the reasons are so
interesting kay is this month for
payroll employees is october is the
first insight that we've had into what
happened to employment numbers after
that iconic furlough scheme came to an
end at the end of september we spoke all
the way through the pandemic didn't we
about how when it ended there might be a
cliff edge we might see a real jump in
unemployment so did we well well no is
the short answer in the month of october
the number of payrolled employees in the
uk actually went up by 160 000. it was a
slightly smaller jump than we saw
between august and september but still a
jump now look it's likely that some
people who did lose their jobs after the
fellows again came to an end might still
be going through that process not all of
the people will be registered in these
numbers right now but it's certainly
significant because if the aim of that
scheme was to prevent mass unemployment
this is the first insight we've really
had into whether that worked and it
seems like it did worth mentioning also
okay in this data the vacancies numbers
as well we've heard so much haven't we
over the past few months about this huge
crisis in the labour market and that
continues unfortunately for the third
month in a row now vacancies well up
over a million for the third month in a
row vacancies at record numbers so an
unemployment crisis averted potentially
but there's another very live crisis
still going on in that labour market
yeah i just heard from the chancellor
actually um he says today's numbers are
testament to the extraordinary success
of the furloughs scheme and welcome
evidence that our plan for jobs has
worked he goes on we'll hear more from
helena on that in the next hour but just
before i let you go hello what's going
on with hs2 i got nothing from the
minister
yeah that was interesting wasn't it kay
uh so we're expecting this big uh review
into kind of rail investment on thursday
as the minister uh was sort of hiding
behind there if you like but it's
looking very likely that the government
is going to scrap the eastern leg of
this big hs2 iconic hs2 project that's
the leg that would have linked
birmingham
with leeds and its potential as well
that there's also going to be a watering
down of another rail line that was due
to link manchester in leeds so absolute
fury this morning um from from northern
based mps from business leaders from the
local media as well and it's quite a
curious decision kay because although
there was a lot of detractors on hs2
lots of people saying was hugely over
expensive that it overfocused on linking
the big metropolitan cities that it
didn't stop off enough in the small
regional centers and the government will
argue that that's what their updated
plans will do they're going to say we're
going to update the local lines the
local residents will get the benefits
quicker it will be cheaper it will be
better for everyone so despite the fact
that the government might argue they're
answering some of those detractors the
reality is this is a government and a
prime minister who have promised over
and over again this leveling up agenda
and it just doesn't seem does it like
withdrawing a line that had cross-party
support that was really going to benefit
northern cities really plays into that
leveling up agenda so lots of questions
from the prime minister to answer we'll
hear much more about all of these plans
on thursday okay thank you
um here's what the papers
in the north are saying about hs2 the
manchester evening news and a number of
its sister titles carry the same front
page reacting to the decision to abandon
the leg of the hs2 high-speed rail line
that would have run between the midlands
and leeds
let's take a closer look now at that
front page their message the government
choose
the north
just trust me okay yorkshire post
that's the manchester evening news train
spotting
let's have a look at the yorkshire post
should we
there we are they say the decision puts
the government's leveling up agenda
in doubt
quick look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
west to southwesterly winds will keep it
mild this week but will bring rain and
gales to the north and west at times
it's mild and fine for most but it's
quite cloudy and there are some dense
fog patches over southern and eastern
england
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
didn't feel like eight degrees this
morning let me tell you
um now how about this for a wall of
sound check it out
[Music]
okay
take my word for it hundreds of violins
violas and double basses play together
in venezuela as they try and capture the
world record for the world's largest
orchestra musicians from all over the
country play tchaikovsky
and a panel of independent judges now
has to verify that 8097 instruments were
playing all at the same time bit like
jazz or something different if you think
this is the big then do bear in mind the
organizers were originally planning to
have another 4 000 musicians taking part
still to come on the program we're going
to be speaking to major general chip
chapman former head of counter-terror at
the ministry of defense as the terror
threat is raised from the explosion in
liverpool that's coming up next
[Music]
government ministers have warned about
the increasing threat in britain from
so-called lone wolf terrorists it comes
after police named the man who they
believe detonated an improvised bomb
outside a hospital in liverpool as imad
al swell mean sky news understands he's
an asylum seeker from a middle eastern
country and had mental health issues a
short time ago i asked the securities
minister damian hines about the
so-called lone wolf threat
you should be concerned of course so i
mean we use the term lone wolf a lot
sometimes it's it's a bit it can be a
little a little misleading because it
gives a certain picture
of of an individual but it certainly is
true that we've seen a move over time a
shift from um these sort of
what we call directed attacks you know
part of a bigger organization where
people are following
uh instructions sometimes quite complex
in their organization and move from that
to
more
self-directed some self-radicalized
individuals or small groups rarely
totally totally alone because people
talk to one another they take advice
they give hints
but yes there has been that move
let's speak now to the former head of
counter terror at the ministry of
defense major general chip chapman hello
t chip good to talk to you so i moved to
towards whatever you want to call them
lone wolves uh murdering thugs whatever
you want to call them but uh solo
operators
yeah the baseline at the moment used by
cantos commanders from march 2017 of the
14 attacks we've had since then 12 have
been lone actors i say lone actors
rather than lone wolf because lone wolf
sort of suggests that people are cunning
and certainly this last attack the
terrorism or not terrorism
he was not a mastermind you don't take a
taxi to a terror attack and he wasn't
cunning so he's a lone actor he's not
really a lone wolf
what factors are considered we know that
the terror leather has been increased
and what factors it can take into
consideration before that happens or
indeed before they're lowered
well i think you have to look at the
last time we went to this and the last
time we went down was due to a
significant reduction in momentum which
followed the attacks between september
and november in europe last year that
was three in france one in
austria germany and switzerland so it's
looking at the momentum and looking at
the background chatter from the
intelligence agencies which then needs
jtac joint terrorism analysis center to
make a determination however things can
be both bad and better at the same time
so for example in december 2017 the
intelligence and security committee said
that we'd be at severe
for at least five years we've actually
come down to substantial a number of
times during that period so you know
things can be improving whilst they're
still bad at the same time
yeah but we came down and then this
happened in liverpool we're not sure
what this guy was planning whether
it was to attack the hospital and cause
death and destruction there or whether
as has been reported suggested that he
originally asked the cab driver to take
him to a remembrance day service at the
cathedral one of the two cathedrals in
london so again i suppose one has to
wonder what has to be taken into account
for
terror threats to be taken down or
indeed to be increased
that's right and this is what makes this
particular attack problematic
problematic because under the terrorism
act 2000 to be called a terrorist event
it's going to have a political religious
ideological or racial motivation it's
not quite clear here what that might be
particularly the fact that he for
example converted to christianity now if
that is true and he was still enduring
obviously you know christian shouldn't
attack people but he would
by himself be mocked for death by
islamic state because he would be deemed
to be an apostate from islam that's uh
under a process called tac fear if you
reverse the coin on that there's also a
thing called taqiyya which is deception
to hide your true events if i was to put
my money on anything i'd say that this
is a disturbed young man who's got
mental health problems and although
people don't like people saying that
about 27
people who take part in terrorist
attacks are vulnerable due to mental
health issues
good to talk to you chip chapman thanks
very much indeed for your expertise as
always thank you
ali is with us um ali what did you make
what the minister was saying about
liverpool
i thought it was really interesting i
mean it was clear that i think he didn't
want to answer your questions about the
state of the union i think that was
casual yeah he um he made clear that you
know it said it would be a few weeks
before we know for sure whether the
attacker acted alone what exactly the
motives were but for me a really
interesting bit was when he was talking
about how we've seen this shift um from
you asking about lone wolves from people
acting on instruction part of bigger
organizations to people being
radicalized acting alone lone wolves um
and that's what we've seen in a lot in
the recent terror attacks including um
david amis uh last month of course um
and he said that there was a concern to
about lockdown which i thought was
really interesting people have been
spending so much time in front of
computer screens he said that that could
have caused a very very small number he
said of people to be radicalized so i
thought there were two interesting
points there from damien hines but it
was took quite a lot of questioning from
you i think to get those answers out
yeah he also didn't have uh didn't want
to uh make any comment really about the
allegations against stanley johnson this
morning no that's right um i he
said that it was the first time he'd
seen the allegations this is obviously
beth rigby's report which contains
allegations that caroline knocks says
stanley johnson had acted
inappropriately at the 2003 conservative
party conference he
has denied that he
said he had nothing to say he said he
didn't even know who caroline knocks was
but yeah very clear that um that the
minister did not want to be drawn on
that he did though say that the
government take all issues around
women's safety very seriously but he
didn't want to link that to those
allegations about stanley johnson okay
um and your take at nine o'clock correct
yeah looking forward to it thanks very
much indeed thanks a lot meantime the
united states says a secret russian
weapons test in space is endangering the
lives of seven astronauts including two
russians aboard the international space
station
this test will significantly increase
the risk to astronauts and cosmonauts on
the international space station as well
as to other human space flight
activities russia's dangerous and
irresponsible behavior jeopardizes the
long-term sustainability of outer space
and clearly demonstrates that russia's
claims of opposing the weapons
weaponization of space are disingenuous
and hypocritical
okay milan is standing by in the
newsroom for us uh what more do you know
about this story melania good morning
good morning kay it was quite a dramatic
turn of events crew had to scramble to
spacecraft that act as live boats really
in case they need a quick getaway to
earth and at the speeds that the space
station orbits more than 17 000 miles
per hour even a small impact could have
really catastrophic consequences we've
heard that from the u.s state department
that russia was responsible for this
saying that russia tested a missile
and shot down an old russian satellite
calling it reckless and irresponsible we
haven't heard from the russian military
or the russian ministry of defense the
russian space agency ross cosmos
downplayed the threat saying that the
objects as they called the debris were
now away from the orbit of iss but it's
worth noting this is not the first
weapons test conducted in space russia
has done it before the us has done it so
have china and india and experts say
that this kind of debris
created from this type of a weapons test
can stay in the orbit for decades really
impose a threat to all objects there
including the hubble telescope the
chinese space station and the
international space station
thanks very much indeed thanks a lot
meantime there was a very early alarm
call for people in western scotland this
morning just after 2 am an earthquake
with a magnitude of 3.1 was felt the
epicenter was 11 miles outside the town
oh they're going to correct me on this
one lock
gill ped
there were reports of tremors in
edinburgh and also in northern ireland
if i pronounce that wrong i'm very sorry
please tell me how to pronounce it on
twitter
politely would be great now mps will
hear about alleged racism at yorkshire
cricket club when former player azim
rafiq appears before a parliamentary
committee this morning we can speak now
to mr affleck's lawyer jen robinson
hello mr robinson thank you very much
indeed for joining us on the program
this morning um what are the contents of
the legal claim that was filed against
yorkshire cricket club by rafiq
azeem brought a claim against yorkshire
county cricket club because of racial
discrimination and victimization that he
faced as a whistleblower speaking out
about the racism that he suffered at the
club now that claim has since been
settled with the new chairman of
yorkshire lord patel so today it really
will be about azim explaining to the
parliamentary committee his experience
of racism at the club and why he's
chosen to speak out
does he feel vindicated given that the
claim has been settled
of course he feels vindicated because
not just because the claim has been
settled but because the club has taken
the first important steps towards
creating change at the club implementing
an anonymous whistleblower system to
ensure that no one goes through what
azim went through in raising concerns
about racism within the club this is the
change that he set out to
put in motion by speaking out to make
sure that no one goes through what he
went through so that young british asian
players feel welcomed and supported at
the club and don't suffer what he
suffered and so seeing others feeling
the ability now to speak out after he
has i think is certainly the vindication
that he needs and he will continue to
advocate for change in the sport
did he receive an apology did he receive
a financial settlement
there was a financial settlement and
also an apology made by lord patel the
new york share chairman who said that he
should never have faced
the treatment that he faced he should
never have been treated the way the club
treated him and that the club is very
sorry they apologize to him to and to
his family and have assured him that the
club is going to put in place the
changes that are needed to make the
place more inclusive for everyone in the
sport and i think this is a positive
first step but of course azim will
continue to advocate for the change that
he thinks needs to happen and as we're
hearing with more and more players
coming forward this is a watershed
moment for qriket it's breaking the
silence around racism and hopefully
we'll see positive changes
has he been asked to be part of the
solution when it comes to yorkshire
county cricket club
for now azeem is happy to to let lord
patel take the changes that he needs to
to make and nazim will continue to be
involved in various charities he's
already been announced today as an
ambassador for a mental health charity
he was of course left suicidal and had
mental health issues as a result of the
treatment he faced and so azim will find
a number of different ways uh both
inside and outside of qriket to continue
to advocate for to what to bring an end
to racism and to be a positive
ambassador for kids coming through the
sport
you mentioned the fact that he was
speaking at the select committee later
on today 9 30 covering it live here on
sky news um what do you what can we
expect from that
well this is of course the first public
and independent opportunity um and forum
in which azeem will be able to tell his
story i think the public will hear more
about what actually happened
the public will hear more about the way
the club treated him the way they tried
to cover this up and the azim really
wanted to resolve this in in an amicable
way and it's really
all of this controversy has happened
because the club didn't listen and do
the right thing and i think it's it's
important that politicians hear this and
that this committee process can be part
of uh pushing for more change in the
sport
um have you worked um on cases like this
in in the past
i've not worked in cases
i've worked with whistleblowers of
course and i've worked with women who
are fighting for change in the sport and
azim i think is really at the forefront
of
um as a whistleblower on racism and
sport and bringing this to the attention
of yorkshire we're now seeing more and
more cricketers come forward and of
course the courage that he's shown in
speaking out is now encouraging others
to do the same so
i you know i hope he you know he won't
be the he will be the first and perhaps
not the last but let's hope that others
will find it easier after what he's been
through
yeah i just wondered what your reaction
was when he came to you and he talked to
you about some of the challenges that he
had faced over a you know considerably
long period of time
my initial reaction was that he he was
someone who was taking a very principled
stance he was motivated by the black
lives matter movement he was devastated
by what had happened to him and he
really wanted to make sure that kids
coming up through the club wouldn't go
through what he went through and that
was his primary motivation throughout
throughout all of this
he wanted to see the changes in the club
that are now starting to happen under
lord patel's leadership and we hope that
that will continue and i really want to
pay tribute to him his courage and
coming forward
he you know it's been a very difficult
year for him he was suicidal when he
left the club because of what happened
he's continued to suffer because of the
attacks that he's faced that we as his
lawyers have faced for bringing these um
complaints forward and it's really a you
know a testament to him and to his
family the support that they've given
him to be able to get through what he's
been through
do you anticipate other cricketers may
well now come forward to you as well at
other clubs um
throughout
not only perhaps the united kingdom but
other parts of the world as well um
feeling emboldened given what we've
heard from azim rafiq
uh already there are cricketers coming
forward with similar stories and not
just in england as you say we've heard
cricketers from essex come forward in
the past few days but i've been
contacted by players in south africa in
india and pakistan this issue and what
azeem has done in speaking out in
breaking this silence is encouraging
people to come out around the world and
talk about their experiences and that
can only be a positive thing for the
game it's important that we create an
inclusive space in all sports in every
aspect of society that people from a
diverse background can succeed and be
supported and that's what i think is so
important about what azeem has done and
the conversation that's now happening in
parliament and around the world and
within the sport and i think azim should
be very proud of what he's done enabled
to enable this conversation and to see
the changes that we're now seeing
and do you anticipate other cricket
boards around the world will have a
similar reaction to what you have seen
um from the ecb in in the united kingdom
well i think everyone is watching what's
happening in england so of course there
are serious questions being asked about
the ecb and whether the ecb intervened
when they should have and have done all
they could have to
make sure that cricket is the safe space
that it ought to be so i think there are
real questions being asked about the way
the ecb has conducted themselves and
that's important that we improve the
regulator for the support for the sport
and that we see
positive changes implemented elsewhere
so i certainly hope that this is just
the beginning of what is uh the
necessary change that we need for qriket
someone i'm trying to contact you via
email there i think probably a seam
ahead of giving evidence later on so we
better let you go it's good to talk to
you thank you very much indeed for
joining us on the programme thank you
full coverage actually others in refix
evidence to the digital culture media
and sport committee that's from 9 30
this morning here on sky news
did you know that air pollution isn't
just bad for the environment it's bad
for our health too
[Music]
parts of scotland and northern ireland
will turn wet and windy through the
morning elsewhere it'll be mostly dry
but rather cloudy with dense fog in the
south and east slow to clear it'll be
mild but windy for many southern and
eastern scotland and northern england
will see increasingly light and patchy
rain later while the northwest will see
rain giving way to sunshine and showers
looking at the uk's air pollution
southwesterly winds will keep levels low
measuring one to three on the daily air
quality index
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
now you probably remember this earlier
this year we featured the story of liam
scott a five-year-old cancer patient his
family were raising money so he could go
to new york remember and receive new
treatment which uh a bit like a vaccine
against the disease that he was
suffering from it's a radical new idea
surely
it couldn't possibly work was what was
being suggested at the time well guess
what
it did
liam his mum claire and dad michael all
with us now hello to you
hello
hi hello
hello liam
hello
hello
how are you this morning have you only
just woken up
well yeah
yeah yeah that's fair enough that's fair
enough it's still early claire tell us
what happened
well liam was diagnosed with a high risk
neuroblastoma cancer a day after i had
kylie
so i'd just given birth and the day
after kylie was
born liam was diagnosed and he had to
start chemotherapy that day
the
the chances of um
of survival were extremely low 40 to 50
chance and
you went through
the most grueling treatment there was
high-dose chemotherapy
to shrink the tumor then there was a um
a six and a half hour operation to
remove the tumor after that he had a
bone marrow
[Music]
harvesting and then high dose
chemotherapy and a bone marrow
transplant to try and get his body back
up and running quickly
it was the most horrific experience and
it's so traumatic for parents to go
through all of this and we found out
about a vaccine that could potentially
save his life
and we the only problem was it was very
very expensive it was around a quarter
of a million pounds
we we didn't know how we were going to
come up with the sum of money we we just
knew we had to have this vaccine for
liam and uh
although we went into lockdown it was
terrifying and liam was so so ill they
literally bring the children to the
brink of death and then resuscitate them
this is how grueling the treatment is
and and during that time the parents are
having to fundraise it's it's just so it
it's the most
i i don't have words for it
no no person should have to go through
this
and he did yes michael let me ask
michael if i may let me jump in there
claire michael how did you manage to
fundraise given that it was locked down
and we were in the middle of the
pandemic and i'm guessing it was just so
difficult to try to find the money but
you knew that you needed it
yeah and i think what makes it really
difficult is that like claire was saying
um you know
your child is going through this
frontline treatment and they're really
quite poorly they're quite ill and then
um the vaccine has to be given um you
know uh at pretty much about three weeks
after the treatment ends the frontline
treatment so um
you know you have to do this fundraising
you know during you know some quite
serious cancer treatment and you've got
a small window to really raise the money
so with lockdown we were quite anxious
in terms of what type of fundraising uh
events you know we'd be able to uh get
involved and to actually raise the money
but
um as you know we had some some some
help from some really wonderful people
um charlie holmes and myself obviously
paddled across the the english channel
from france to england
um and uh charlie also got involved in
some some
uh running on his treadmill which which
went live on instagram and and and took
off and and helped sort of get the
the ball rolling and then also you know
we had some wonderful support from
people
all over the uk as well as the world
let me get let me get a word in from
liam if i may liam um how are you
feeling now
you're great you're back at school am i
am i writing saying you're back at
school
well right now i have a cough right now
but it's getting better there
getting better you're loving school yeah
i'm loving school though okay what's
your favorite subject at school
well
i like math
yeah you like maths
wow that's impressive
you're going to be a mathematician when
you grow up or are you going to be a
doctor
well a doctor
maybe a footballer probably a footballer
yeah well he actually wants to be a
doctor
hey that's great
sadly we are out of time it's so lovely
to see him looking so well thanks mum
and dad for taking the time to join us
high five liam
high five hi okay i just wanted to say
we we
just a quick quick one i just wanted to
say time i'm so sorry
no sorry sorry
all right
[Music]